hey guys today I want to share with you
a hack and some useful information they
contentiously use to improve the power
of your sleep for learning and creative
problem-solving I was a little bit
pushed for time this week so didn't have
time to film in the office as usual I
thought what would box for being home of
the dreaming spires and of course Oxford
University this might be quite a good
setting for what I'm going to talk about
today so I got the bulk of what I'm
going to talk about here from a TED talk
by penny Lewis and if you want the full
context that I highly recommend you go
and check that out I'll leave the link
in the description down below so know
you studied psychology will know that
when we get to sleep we go through five
different stages stage 1 2 3 4 then REM
sleep and REM sleep is of course when we
dream and this is associated with
creativity and problem-solving but the
other stages of sleep are also important
you have the first stage which is your
light sleep and then stages 3 & 4 which
are deep sleep and slow-wave sleep and
stage 2 which I guess is just kinda in
the middle and this is where you get the
sleep spindles which I'll be talking
about in a moment you go through
multiple cycles of these stages during
any single night's sleep each one
lasting about 90 210 minutes and that's
why if you're going to power nap that's
very important you either wake up in
your light sleep before you reach stage
2 & 3 or that you sleep for 90 minutes
and do at least one complete cycle the
first cycle of sleep is the most
important for bodybuilders and anyone
found build muscle because this is when
you produce the most growth hormone and
testosterone but the other stages of
sleep are also interesting and in this
talk by penny Lewis she talked about how
memory seems to be consolidated during
slow-wave sleep and deep sleep and how
this also correlates with sleep spindles
in stage 2 so in one study they taught
participants these hand movements which
involved things like this and got them
to rote learn them then after a night's
sleep they found that their ability to
perform those actions quickly improved
by 20% so we already know that sleep is
very important for learning anything in
this shows that it also applies to
learning motor movements which is
something that should be of interest to
anyone learning a kata for martial art
or dance choreography we all knew that
like I said they what's more interesting
is that the
extent to which their ability to perform
these movements improved correlated with
the amount of sleep spindles that they
had during their stage to sleep these
sleep spindles being high frequency
oscillations in their brainwaves in
specific brain regions and specifically
it correlated with this activity in the
motor cortex which is of course the part
of the brain responsible for motor
movements moving your arms and legs etc
and feeling feedback from your limbs and
body parts who might then think that
sleep spindles must be responsible for
that memory consolidation but in another
study it was found that this
consolidation also occurs in deep stages
of sleep stages 3 & 4 in this study they
took a computer game players and got
them to learn the maps of virtual
environments and then they monitored
their brain activity during sleep and
during stages 3 & 4 if they showed more
activity in the hippocampus which is a
brain region that's responsible for
spatial reasoning and memory among other
things then they showed greater
improvement in their abilities to
navigate these virtual environments so
it's not so much the sleep spindles that
important rather it's the activation in
the relevant rain areas during those
sleep stages that it might just be that
looking at sleep spindles and where they
occur could be a useful indicator of
what reactivation will occur in which
brain regions during sleep so that's all
very interesting but what's more useful
from a biohacking perspective is that
you can also induce this reactivation
during sleep in specific brain regions
by creating associations so if you play
a certain sound whilst the learning and
movement or factual information and then
you play that sound back to yourself
whilst you're sleeping then you can
trigger reactivation through association
in those brain regions and improve your
ability to consolidate those specific
memories as you're sleeping so rather
than learning something all day going to
bed and hoping that you consolidated
during the night you can create an
association by playing music or just by
listening to the sounds that are related
to what you're doing and then playing
that back to yourself whilst you sleep
let me show you how this works if I show
you a cat
in this part of the screen and a dog in
this part of the screen and then tonight
when you're asleep and you enter
slow-wave sleep I'm watching and I play
then the next day when I test you you'll
be much more likely to remember where
the cat was on the screen than the dog
and that's because that sound cue will
have triggered reactivation of the
memory hacking any system means looking
at the inputs and then seeing how you
can use those inputs to manipulate said
system and in biohacking it's no
different whilst we're sleeping we can
still hear this is of course how we
listen out for predators and this is why
alarm clocks are effective at waking us
up so this is a useful way of literally
hacking sleep in order to potentially
improve our memory so I don't know if
people are trying this themselves and if
they've had any luck but it's certainly
very interesting something I'll be
trying and give it go as well and let me
know in the comments down below if it
helps you to consolidate new information
or new movement patterns more quickly
and on a related note REM sleep which is
responsible for dreams seems to serve
the role of associative problem-solving
so the reigning theory at the moment is
that when we're dreaming we're
reactivating brain areas and not only
consolidating those memories but seeing
how they fit to other related brain
regions so for instance finding how
something fits contextually with other
information that you have and maybe how
this can help you to solve a problem and
so this is why when we sleep on a
problem often we wake up with a solution
and dreams have always been a great
resource for creative individuals and
many people have credited their dreams
with helping them to count with sonatas
or great works of art or stories so the
problem with using dreams creatively is
that we often can't remember the useful
information that we come up with whilst
we're sleeping however during stage one
sleep we go through a similar brain
state called hypnagogia or and
hypnagogic state and during this time
this is when your thoughts start to
become a little bit muddled you might
notice yourself thinking things that are
a little bit weird and there is a way
that we can make sure that we remember
and consciously become aware of these
thoughts more often the way we do this
is simply by making sure that we wake up
at the moment that we start drifting
into that state and the method that
Salvador Dali would use to do
come on it is pretty weird paintings is
he would go to sleep on a couch or on a
chair and hold a spoon in one hand and
hold the spoon over a plate and the idea
was that once he started to drift off
and lose consciousness he would then
drop the spoon it would land on the
plate and clatter and wake him up and
then he'd write down whatever weird
stuff it was he was thinking or
visualizing at that point in time
thereby coming up with me crazy strange
paintings that he's known for so that's
just a fun little experiment you can use
to tap into your brain slightly more
creative state whilst you're sleeping
but I mainly wanted to share that
interesting information about how you
could link information with sounds and
then use that to reactivate brain
regions and potentially improve your
learning and a similar technique could
likewise potentially be used to help you
cope with associative problem-solving
while sleeping so if you found either of
those things useful or interesting then
please leave a like down below comment
and let me know what you think
especially if you try it let me know if
you have any amazing breakthroughs or if
you can more quickly learn a new motor
skill and stay tuned if you want more
like this on brain training bodybuilding
fitness self development technology
working online transhumanism nootropics
all that usual stuff if that sounds good
then thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time bye for now